Transcriber: Lamia AlMohaimeed
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
لتبني أكبر وأعظم بناء في العالم .
يوجد طريقتان الأولى أن تبني أعظم وأكبر
بناء في العالم
أما الثانية أن تبني بناء متواضعا
وتعمل على هدم المباني الأعلى
والأفضل ، أو على الأقل أن تفرح بزوالها .
وفق هذه العقلية وهي العقلية الأكثر رواجا .
أكثر شخص سعيد باعتزال روجيه
فيدرر هو نادال .
صحيح ، ولكن على العكس ، نادال كان أكثر شخص
حزينا لاعتزال روجيه فيدرير
وذلك لأن محفزه الأول والأقوى
على تطوير أدائه مشى
فالند يعرف بنده
أكثر خمس دول تنافسا على الصدارة
كأفضل دول العالم في التعليم هي
سنغافورة ، اليابان ، فنلندا ،
كوريا الجنوبية وكندا .
انتقيت لكم ثلاثة أمثلة مختلفة على اننا
نجد أنفسنا بإحداها
معكم سالي المعاذ مدرِّسة .
وترجمان محلف
إلى من يميل إلى طريقة التدريس في
البرنامج وهي الطريقة الهادئة .
إليكم هذا البلد الصاعد تعليميا فنلندا .
فنلندا تهتم كثيرا بالأنشطة والمهارات
والاكتشاف الحر أكثر بكثير مما
تهتم بكمية المعلومات
، كما وتهتم أيضا بطريقة التعليم
التعاوني وهي عكس التنافسي
فالطريقة التنافسية والتي تتبناها
أمريكا وبريطانيا
مثلا يعني أن هناك رابح وخاسر
أما في الطريقة التعاونية فلا يوجد
طالب مجد أخر كسول
لأن المدرسة ليست فقط للتعليم
بل لتنمية الشخصية والقدرات .
التعليم في فنلندا مجاني ليس فقط في سوريا
مجاني
ولكن التعليم في فنلندا يضمن وجود مساعد
متخصص لذوي الهمم
وذوي المهارات أو الحاجات الخاصة كمثل
صعوبات الحركة
وصعوبات التعلم وذلك لتأمين
مستوى عادل للجميع .
وأيضا هناك مواد في فنلندا مرتبطة جدا بحياة
الفرد
فمثلا يوجد مادة تدعى مادة التدبير
المنزلي وهي موجهة للجنسين
تعلم هذه المادة علم التغذية وعلم الطعام
كما أن هناك أسلوبا لتعليم الطالب
إدارة الأسرة والبيئة .
يوجد مادة تدعى بمادة الصحة وتهدف إلى
زيادة الوعي في في أمن الطالب النفسي
والبدني .
تنفرد فنلندا بمادة تدعى مادة المشورة
التعليمية وهي تدرس من السابع وحتى التاسع .
تهدف هذه المادة إلى تعريف الطالب إلى ميوله
كما وتهدف على تحسين قدرته على اختيار ما
ينفعه في المستقبل .
إلى من يقول بأن الرجعية هي السبب الأساسي
لإيقاف تطور أنظمة التعليم في العالم .
إليكم سنغافورة .
سنغافورة هي جزيرة صغيرة فقيرة
بدأت نهضتها من تحت الصفر .
ففي عام ألف وتسعمائة وتسعة وستين كان الناس
في سنغافورة يستحمون في الشوارع .
لكم أن تتخيلوا حجم الوعي الاجتماعي
والثقافي والفكري لهكذا بلد .
ولكن بعد ثمان وأربعين عام أي في عام ألفين
وثمانية عشر
اعتلت أفضل الأنظمة التعليمية
في العالم .
طبعا الأمر لم يكن بتلك
السهولة على الإطلاق .
طالبت كثيرا بمساعدات دولية وعادت طلباتها
بالرفض فاعتمدت على ذاتها .
في عام ٢٠٠٧
أنفقت سنغافورة سبعة
مليارات دولار على التعليم
أي ما يقارب خمس ميزانية سنغافورة .
أما المناهج في سنغافورة فهي ليست كثيرة ولا
تعتمد على كثرة المواد أو المعلومات ،
٣٠٪ معارف علوم ، ٤٠٪
أخلاقيات عامة
و ٣٠٪ فنون ومسرح وموسيقى .
تدرس سنغافورة الرياضيات بطريقة ممتعة جدا
، كما وتهتم بالسرعة في الإجابة .
تهتم جدا أيضا بدمج التكنولوجيا في التعليم
لسنغافورة قدرة ابتكارية وإبداعية في
التعليم
فهي تركز على وجود عدة إجابات
لسؤال واحد ، وهذا يعزز التفرد والتميز .
أما التركيز على طريقة واحدة فذلك يجعل
من الطلبة نسخا لإجابة واحدة .
لي كوان يو هو مؤسس سنغافورة
ورئيس وزرائها الأسبق
وصاحب المقولة الشهيرة أن تنظيف
الفساد مثل تنظيف الدرج .
فكر مليا لمحاولة رفع مستوى بلاده مما كانت
عليه الى هنا الى ما هي عليه الان .
وخلصت إلى مجموعة عوامل
منها اكتشاف مهارات الطلاب وهواياتهم
والعمل على تعزيزها
كما أيضا اهتم بالاهتمام بذوي الهمم
ودمجهم في الوظائف .
عمل على توفير أنظمة تعليمية تهدف إلى تطوير
شخصية الطالب
تكامل تام بين مؤسسات الدولة لينتج عنه
نظاما تعليميا مركزيا مرن ومتجانس .
في عام ٢٠٠٧ كانت سنغافورة أفضل دول
العالم
في تدريس العلوم والرياضيات
، ففكرت كاليفورنيا باستخدام مناهج
الرياضيات في سنغافورة .
من الغرائب لي كوان يو عندما توفي
لم يشيع لا من منزله ولا من سدة رئاسته
بل شيع من الجامعة
كم هو مؤثر
بمرحلة من المراحل كان هذا البلد
أتعرفونه ؟
نعم هو اليابان .
كان هذا البلد في مرحلة من المراحل بنفس
مستوى بلادنا الان أي في عام ألف وتسعمائة
وخمسة وأربعين وهو عام سقوط
هيروشيما وناغازاكي .
ولكن سرعان ما تطور هذا البلد لأنه
اعتمد على تطوير التعليم لديه .
وعلى عكس فنلندا ، يعشق النظام الياباني
الضغط في التعليم ، فبعد أن ينتهي الطالب
صباحا من مدرسته وما يتبعها من عمليات
توظيف يذهب إلى الجوكو
هي مدرسة مسائية تهتم بتعزيز قدرات الطالب
وما تعلمه في الصباح
وذلك لتأهيله الى المدرسة الثانوية
وما يتبعها من امتحان
يقال عنه امتحان الموت .
أقل ما يقال عن هذا الامتحان انه امتحان
صعب للغاية يهدف الى تعريف الطالب الى
الكلية المناسبة التي سيدخلها فيما بعد
كما وتعرفه على مستواه الاجتماعي وراتبه
أما المناهج في اليابان فهي مناهج ثرية جدا
فهي تهتم كثيرا بالفضول وتهتم بالمثابرة
والضمير الحي ، كما وتهتم ايضا
بتعزيز الثقة لدى الطالب .
فالذكاء والحفظ ليس سؤال مهارتي الأساسيتين
لتحديد مستوى الطالب .
كما تهتم أيضا بالوحدة والجماعة فهي تعلم
الطالب منذ صغره أن فشله بشيء معين يعني
فشل اليابان .
أما الدقة والانضباط فهي ما يميز الشعب
الياباني ومنذ زمن وذلك لأنه تعلمها في
المدرسة فأصبحت هي العامل
الرئيسي وراء نجاحه .
صدقوني يا كرام اليابان ليست كوكباً على
الإطلاق
هي مجرد بلد منضبط بأخلاق
وقوانين .
الان ما المستفاد من هذه الخلاصات الثلاثة
في ظل الحال الذي نعيشه ؟ في الماضي كان
يقال عماد المدرسة أستاذ وطالب وكتاب
أما الان فيوجد عنصر جديد وهو عنصر الإدارة
التعليمية المرنة .
والسؤال هنا
هل نستورد نظاما من الأنظمة الأنفة الذكر
مثلا ونطبقها كما هي ؟
في الواقع أن الحكمة ضالة المؤمن .
يجب علينا النظر الى جميع التجارب الناجحة
والفاعلة مع محاولة اصطياد التقنيات
المناسبة ، فالعالم اليوم واحد وبالتالي
مشاكله متقاربة فما المانع من الاقتباس ؟
ولكن في المقابل هل لكل .
لكل تعليم أهداف
فهل أهدافنا هنا في الشام
تشبه أهدافهم ؟ وأيضا لا يمكن لنظام
مهما كان ناجحا البقاء والاستمرار طويلا
وذلك بسبب تغير وتبدل المقاييس والمعايير
عبر الزمان والمكان .
فالمعايير تحديد أفضل الأنظمة التعليمية
هما معيارين الأول تناسبه مع باقي الأنظمة
في الدولة ، و تناسبه مع البيئة .
ثانيا عبقرية النتائج
إذا ما دخلنا الى المسابقات العالمية
واستمرار هذه العبقرية
فمثلا العوائل الراقية في اليابان
تبدأ بتعليم أطفالها منذ الصغر أسئلة الدخول
امتحان جامعة طوكيو لماذا ؟
لأن أربعين بالمئة من المدراء التنفيذيين
الناجحين في
اليابان هم من خريجي هذه الجامعة
رغم وجود ثلاثمائة جامعة أخرى .
متطلبات التطور في الماضي تختلف كثيرا
عما هي عليه الان في الماضي .
أراضي واسعة .
موقع استراتيجي وبترول .
اما الان .
تعليم جيد .
تربية مرنة وحرة في الأسر والمدارس .
مراكز للتدريب .
مراكز للبحث .
غنية وثرية .
ونظام تعليمي مرن .
إذا المطلوب اليوم إنسان من نوع جديد .
فان سنغافورة ذات المساحة الصغيرة والعدد
السكاني الصغير
الانف الذكر مقدراتها تقارب
مصر ذات المئة مليون نسمة
والألف كيلومتر مربع .
من جانب اخر لإيجاد نهضة جديدة
ومستمرة يجب علينا التركيز على
ما يلي تدريب الإنسان ،
تطوير عقله والاهتمام بالجانب الخلقي
لديه وتحديدا بضبط الذات .
فالعصر اليوم معروف بأنه عصر الإدارة .
عصر السرعة .
عصر التكنولوجيا .
عصر الذكاء الصنعي .
وعصر التخلف الأخلاقي أيضا .
ولكن إذا ما نظرنا إلى الأخلاق المرتبطة
بالعمل نجدهم قد اعتنوا بها كثيرا .
أمانة في الأداء .
التزام بالوقت والمعايير .
مصداقية بذكر المواصفات .
جدية في العمل .
إذن لا يمكن أن يوجد تطور بأي منحى من مناحي
الحياة
بمعزل عن الالتزام والانضباط .
في العودة إلى نقطة البحث الأصلية يقول
الدكتور عبدالله الدنان صاحب نظرية تعلم
اللغة العربية عن طريق الفطرة يقول بأن
أفضل طريقة للتعليم هي بإحياء الفضول
العلمي لدى الطلاب .
وضرب لنا مثلا عن أسئلة المناهج لدينا .
فاسمعوا يا كرام هذه الجملة .
كانت المرأة تنظف منزلها
بعد أن خرج أطفالها صباحا إلى
المدرسة وهي تحني ظهرها
أسئلة الكتاب ماذا كانت تفعل المرأة ؟
إلى أين ذهب الأطفال ؟
متى ذهب الأطفال ؟ أي أن
الأسئلة مباشرة .
ولكن إذا سألنا هل كانت المكنسة طويلة أم
قصيرة ؟
نجد بعض الطلبة وبعض أوليائهم
يقولون بأن الأسئلة من خارج المنهاج .
ولكن إذا ما نظرنا إلى عبارة وهي تحني ظهرها
نجد أن ساعد المكنسة كان قصيرا .
أي أن مناهجنا لا تساعد على الاستنتاج .
أما فيما يخص معركة تعليم التاريخ
فلدينا قاعدة هامة جدا ودقيقة جدا
تقول كلما كثرت
لدينا الوقائع سواء بالتجربة العملية أو
بالقراءة كلما كبرت قاعدة القياس .
كبر قاعدة القياس يعني قدرتنا على استنباط
الحلول للمشاكل الماضية والقدرة على
تطويعها لما يتناسب مع مشاكل الحاضر
أي نتعلم الثبات في تعلم التاريخ
هو شرط للوعي
في العالم .
أما فيما يخص الجغرافيا
والتي تعلم بناء العقول الاستراتيجية
فتعلم الجغرافيا يعني
تعلم الممرات في العالم
وبالتالي نستطيع أن نشكل صورة
عن الاقتصاد والشعوب وكيفية
التواصل بين القارات فيما بينها .
للأسف التاريخ والجغرافيا هما أحد المعارك
التي خسرناها ويجب استردادها .
أما فيما يخص تعليم مادة الرياضيات فأكبر
أعدائها
هم بعض مدرسيها عندما قاسوا ذكاء
وغباء الطالب وقدرته على حل مسألة ما .
لتعليم الرياضيات فوائد عديدة
من أهمها أننا نستطيع أن نتحدث
عن موضوع معين بأسلوب
مجرد والتعميم أي إذا ما حللنا معادلة معينة
فجميع المعادلات التي على شاكلتها
تكون قد حلت الانسياب في الفضاءات الأخرى
فتعلم الرياضيات بشكل جيد يعني أننا نستطيع
أن نتعلم العلوم والفيزياء بشكل جيد أيضا
وبالتالي العطب فيها يؤدي إلى العطب بباقي
المواد .
أما تعلم المهني أو الفني كما نقول
التعليم المهني والفني فهو
هام ولا يقل أهمية عن
التعليم الجامعي وذلك لأنه المحرك الرئيس
وراء اقتصاد البلاد إذا ما نظرنا طبعا إلى
التنمية المستدامة .
وهذا يعني أنه يجب علينا تصحيح النظرة
النمطية
الذهنية الطبقية للمجتمع ، فهذا
التعلم هدفان الأول حماية ثقافة الفرد
والمجتمع وأمن اقتصاد البلاد .
الخلاصة أنا أرى أن العلوم على أنواعها
موجودة وتتطور ومنذ زمن ولكن
الربط بين النفس
والواقع المعاش والحياة هو ما يجعل
لها نفعا
وبالتالي الربط بين العلم
بالمجمل وبين النفس والحياة يتناسب طردا
مع ما يعود على المجتمع من نفع ،
فيجب علينا النظر بنظرة تحليلية لواقعنا
تحديد مواطن الحاجة ، الأخذ
من التجارب السابقة
التخطيط للمستقبل ، تعاون الأفراد
وتوحد المجتمع من جهة ، ومن جهة
أخرى نفسية ضبط للنفس ومثابرة
وسعي دائم وحثيث مغلفين بالأخلاق
ينتج عنه بذرة قريبة
الإثمار .
التعليم أمن قومي واستثمار
ناجح ومربح دائما .
فهل أدواتنا الأن تعيننا على التعامل مع
المستقبل ؟
هل نحن نشكل ونربي جيلا قادرا
على التعامل مع الظروف المستقبلية ؟
هل ندعو ونحث على البحث
والتطوير والابتكار ؟
تذكر لكل فرد منا دور منوط فيه القيام به
إذا ما أردنا الوصول إلى ما نطمح له .
فالسفر سيغطي ويعيق السفر والسلام .